folks the wartime propaganda coming out
of the russian invasion is unprecedented
we have never seen anything like this
and social media isn't helping
it's hard to know what to believe
anymore and who to trust
we're living in an information age at
our fingertips but there are serious
doubts over what part which parts of it
are actually true
moscow was increasingly using harsh
tactics to control information about the
war this includes banning facebook and
passing a law that could jail
journalists ukraine's air force says
that russia has carried out an alleged
false flag operation aimed at bringing
belarus into the conflict evolving from
biological hazards to biological weapons
and becoming a key part of russia's
disinformation campaign justifying the
invasion of ukraine
so listen propaganda and war is nothing
new every side's going to do it putin
does it well they twist the truth
but the left here is engaged in
information manipulation too well what
do i mean by that
well let's start with the
self-proclaimed gatekeepers of truth the
media fact checkers who've blown it just
about every week for the past few months
let's fact check the fact checkers
during the show today how about that
fact checker fail number one
according to the truth warriors at
politifact
quote the u.s did not double oil imports
from russia in the last year
see it right there folks well
nice try but it turns out yes the united
states actually did double its crude oil
imports from russia in 2021.
here's the joke of this whole thing
politifact even mentions that
in the 10th paragraph of its original
story sounds like propaganda to me
doesn't it
here's fact checker fail number two who
could forget this gem
when the whole world saw joe biden check
his watch during the ceremony honoring
the fallen u.s service members who died
in afghanistan we watched it
usa today unleashed its fact-checking
army to run interference on that why why
even draw attention to it
the paper then how to write a correction
after their own fake fact check
it's fact check or fail number three we
could go on all day here folks
remember before the kyle rittenhouse
trial politifact insisted quote it's
perfectly legal for rittenhouse to carry
a gun question mark
false but during the actual trial the
judge dismissed the gun charge against
written house and the fact checkers
scrambled to explain away their mistake
listen the media you got one job guys
the ladies out there to keep us informed
with the truth that you're one job
you're one job
and yet you keep failing over and over
but the tide may be turning especially
in the covet information wars
in new york city some vaccination rules
are still intact in fact new york won't
allow unvaccinated athletes to play home
games
but they will let unvaccinated visiting
athletes play in new york
got it even leftist comedian trevor noah
starting to figure out the absurdity of
this
i don't care
like how coveted compliant you are like
this makes zero sense can we agree on
that
can we what so kyrie can go inside not
wear a mask even hug a teammate but he
cannot play
i don't get it why does the ball have a
weak immune system what's going on yeah
i'm glad everybody's waking up uh but
it's a little late right where was
trevor noah when all this madness
started and people like us were getting
poked fun at for bringing it up you know
nba superstar kevin durant though he
said it best
yeah i don't get it it just feels like
at this point now somebody's trying to
make a statement or a point
um to flex their authority so
yeah we're all confused pretty much
everybody in the world is confused at
this point early on in the season
you know people didn't understand what
was going on but now it just looks
stupid you see what happens when people
wake up to propaganda
kevin durant thinks the rules sound
stupid you know why because the rules
are stupid they never made any sense
china imposed the seven day lockdown in
their tech hub shenzhen due to a massive
covet outbreak which is easing now but
there could be more bad news coming up
for our supply chain crisis
but has anyone thought to ask why aren't
we seeing the same outbreak in the
united states
have we attained herd immunity here
you remember the same herd immunity
called not realistic by the media
what he's trying to say is herd immunity
herd immunity is not a realistic way of
dealing with this um pandemic at this
point in time are they talking about
herd immunity uh
and the risks though that are associated
with
that kind of rhetoric about herd
immunity that's not a fundamental
strategy listen unlike the left-wing
media okay i don't do propaganda so i
can't prove we've reached herd immunity
because immunity resistant strains can
always develop
but it hurt immunity it's not a strategy
it's an established phenomenon an
epidemiological phenomenon
just go to the search machine on the
internet look it up it's not a talking
point
it isn't just fact-checkers failing and
the media failing us and the propaganda
everywhere the left's hypocrisy is
actually now getting worse after all of
this remember way back when hillary
clinton accused tulsi gabbard of being
used by the russians during the 2020
primary
tulsi gabbard russian stooge everybody
ever everybody's a russian stooge if
you're not a democrat butt kisser
now democrats have launched a fresh
round of attacks saying tulsi gabbard
took 20 to a 2020 campaign donation from
an accused russian agent wait for it for
an amazing
59.95
sounds like a door dash bill on the
weekend
but conveniently the left somehow
forgets hunter biden's lavish gifts from
foreign powers
check out this headline more money than
god chinese titan lavish thunder biden
with a three carat gem and an offer of
30 million three carat gem it's a little
bit more than a door dash bill on the
weekends right eating a lot of door dash
so to be clear a 59 donation
definitely a russian asset a three carat
diamond from a businessman in china
definitely not a chinese communist party
asset no way
folks between the failed fact checkers
and the constant liberal stream of
misinformation it's like drinking from a
fire hose
the propaganda is not exclusive to
people at war or tyrant vladimir putin
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else